OK, let's go back to the phones, by which
I mean it is scored David Pakman dotcom discord.
I want to hear next from Tamasha to Meesha.
You're on the air.
What's going on?
And David, how are you?
I'm from I'm I'm a teacher in New York City
public schools.
OK, and I'm a teacher, so I work with another
teacher and she we're also good friends.
So she taught me that she voted for Trump.
Well, fundamentally, I don't believe that
you should decide a friendship based on that.
But at the same time, I have feelings like
I felt a way about the fact that she voted
for Trump.
She gave me her reasons.
We talk about it a lot.
But I really still felt right when we got
into an argument about it.
We made up and everything.
But what's so what do you think about maintaining
a friendship?
Well, is it is so you learn she voted for
Trump and that disturbed you.
And then you talked about why how do you feel
about the reasons why she voted for Trump?
Her reasons were based on misinformation,
but I understood where she was coming from.
She said that she was afraid of socialism.
She lives in Jersey and she doesn't like the
government governor, which is democratic and
stuff like that.
And she was a Democrat.
She switched to independent.
And, you know, some reason, like the socialist
part, I was like, you don't really understand
that.
It's not like our country is going to become
socialist.
Right.
I mean, does she think Joe Biden is a socialist?
Well, she really thinks Joe Biden is just
not has dementia, is not she?
You know, it's a lot of that fake news stuff
that she she listens to.
Yeah, that's tough.
I mean, listen, you're in a position where
this is not only a friend, but it's someone
you're working with.
So, you know, I think it's it's a very personal
decision.
The one thought I have is if you don't feel
as though you've learned things about this
person where you believe that you now are
sort of in some way targeted by them or that
they have beliefs which are directly hostile
to you, like, OK, it sounds like you're saying
she fell for the idea that that if Trump loses,
there's going to be socialism.
That was wrong.
But it doesn't necessarily mean that she now
has to have a hostile relationship with you.
Like if you feel as though you disagree with
this person and they're misinformed about
things and have come to the wrong conclusions,
but it's not hostile to you in a direct way,
then I would understand, especially because
you have to work with them, that you maintain
the relationship.
But it's a very personal decision to make.
Yeah, I agree.
I mean, like we talk about politics a lot
because we're both very interesting and she
she does value my opinion.
I value her opinion.
And we talked it out and she I thought I explained
it to her about the whole socialism fear.
And she was like, oh, OK, that makes me feel
better because I really don't want our country
to turn into that.
And she now did you uncurious at some point,
did you say, do you know what socialism is?
Let me understand.
When you say socialism, what do you mean?
And see if she even knows what it is.
Was that something you tried?
Yet she feels like it's like big government
and free everything, and she doesn't like
the idea of universal health care, which I
do.
Yeah, for all.
So she's pretty misinformed about what these
things even are, it sounds like.
Yeah, basically.
But like I said, I don't I still value her
friendship and we're still friends and I don't
let it get to me.
But I did feel a little off-putting about
the fact that she did wind up voting for Trump.
I agree.
But listen, it sounds like all in all, this
is this is very tolerable.
And overall, it sounds like it's more positive
than negative for you.
Yes.
Well, there's your answer.
Thanks.
All right.
Thanks to Meesha.
Keep up the great work teaching in New York.
That's a big deal.